hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to with the addition to
markiplier everybody put your hands in
the air wave them like you only cared
just a little bit but not all that much
Jeremy
David Sarah we're doing I see you out
there
see you now dancin I see you caring too
much no not you Sarah the other Sarah
you're doing just fine but that other
Sarah oh all right so as you can tell my
voice is pretty much back to 100% but
I'm still gonna take it easy with this
game but I have to start over from the
beginning
because I need to know if I can save
yamimash not but if I can that I'm just
gonna keep going so here we go I'm gonna
jump into the future
I just realized is probably also the
option of not picking up tiny box sim
here cuz I could see what that does but
for this particular go I'm gonna pick
him up here and I'm gonna see what's
going on even though this is definitely
not tiny box Tim I know Tim you're know
Tim really back to the fast-forwarding
no no no no no no now I'm ash why'd you
have to drink you didn't have to drink I
was gonna come get you I didn't need to
find a way around I had wings okay so
here we go see if this actually did
something oh but I had wings I had wings
add wings
I had wings oh oh okay so apparently I
can jump over the gap even though I have
wings so I don't know exactly what the
wings would be for I can only assume
that I'm going to return to this place
at some time in the future so with that
being said I'm gonna reload my other
save because it's actually farther along
the game such that I would not be able
to waste you guys as time would be able
to do something that you can enjoy so
here we are we're back yet so I guess
it's just it from now on we're playing
again the lovely game the tiny box Tim
needs to be rescued or something rather
Bob and Wade Bob and Wade
hey yeah I forgot that my face was in
the middle of melting do they recognize
me
babban way more helpless oh hey there
mark oh hi mark how are you oatmeal grit
for knee but other than that I'm okay
we don't have time for this mark you
gotta gotta Boyd know about how you'll
nub the weather been dandy here guys
come on quickly mark get us out
we've had some sunny days I've seen
sunshine and I've seen rain I've seen
sunny days that I thought would never
end
if you know get us out of here now mark
tine box team is gonna what where'd he
come from
did he come out of Wade's back pocket
tiny box Tim let my friends go what do
you mean friend tell you what I'll do
just set I'll let one person go oh I get
to choose I get to choose oh my goodness
I will throw them down the hole here and
they can be eaten by my we're cats
mark would never choose between his
friends who will live
I really wouldn't they're both like my
best friends like I can't believe that
they would make me choose but Canon
states that Wade has already been
devoured by the werecats as was evident
in the king of the werecats
cartoon Bob is the king of the work hat
so if I chose him he might not have been
actually eaten I believe Wade would be
eaten but this is a tough choice to make
this is actually a choice here all right
Wade I pick were hem Bob he picks Bob
Bob you're so noble what Bob lives so
long wait oh oh ah okay I didn't know I
was picking the person to live I thought
I was picking the person to die so who
literally waited was the only one that
could have ever gone in there you may
have Bob see you soon okay Bob thanks I
meant to pick you Bob but I things got
confused come on Bob let's go okay then
pop during the party and went inside of
me whoa whoa Nelly already read too many
fan sections about Philip fan chicks in
fact you know what I meant
eat my addiction whatever easy youtuber
good guy anyway oh do I have to jump
down the hole is Wade being eaten
currently alive by we're cats its Lou
scratching
don't worry wide that should do it
is it cool ranch doritos yeah aunt
Rita's tastes crunchy justice we're cats
yeah uh Wade DynaVox Tim oh he came out
of the crack in the wall wait what
Wade's not dead yet he's just currently
being eaten alive by where cats I think
I got the Cool Ranch Doritos from the
lady statue down in the waterfall so
that was important that was pretty
important that means that Wade is not
dead great another string quartet on my
back absolutely why not
oh god it's no not Jack he didn't even
get to talk I guess yeah Oh Jack I'm so
sorry
I just can't help it this is hilarious
no disrespect to Jack but here we go
oh man oh I love them so much I love me
some rattle soda with sansei walls walls
all around
blue balls on one will make a sound so
you want me to put my balls up on the
wall is that what you're saying you want
me to go balls to the wall so I'm
supposed to take some interpretation
about that some Shakespearean [ __ ] going
on here I got to put my blue balls to
the wall so that they make a sound if
blue balls fall in forest and no one's
around to hear it does this joke make
any sense the blue ball starts to glow
wait what what blue ball what blue ball
I don't see a blue ball what are you
talk
ah I guess you could say that Boulder
just rocked your world
thanks thanks Bob thanks Bob thank you
thank you Bob Bob you're just the best
so what am i doing oh this sounds like
royalty free music definitely hello mark
Tim listen to me you don't have to do
this I know that you're good inside just
fight the urge to be a douche fight
fight
you will die markiplier mark you won't
get through to him
I have rigged myself with bombs you'll
never escape in time what are you
talking about what uh I'm coming for you
boy these bombs are heavier than I
thought mark I think I'll be going
okay bye Bob uh Tim I think I'll be
going too no way there's only like 20
more seconds until the explosion oh but
I I don't get to make a choice
wait whoa I am making a choice here
waddle oh oh oh oh oh who's it supposed
to go anywhere oh boy here okay I can't
move anymore Bob no come back Bob is
Wade still being eaten alive by werecats
yeah baby hey wait how's it going I
meant to pick you wait you're alive the
Cool Ranch Doritos worked for some
reason those Cool Ranch Doritos saved in
my life mark I'm so grateful
I'm just happy Year's Eve thanks mark
let's get out of here Iggy
what the heck was that where your
babbling wait let's go already
okay Wade well you managed to save Wade
commendable in itself but you still have
not seen the true ending try again and
find the blue ball in mysterious - what
oh the blue ball was like on one the
sidewalk I don't know where the stash
was y know where it was it was with what
Oh what huh
um what was I supposed to do you're
gonna find the blue ball in the
mysterious - ah poop
I can't go back ah ah alrighty then
okay bear with me I'm gonna try to find
this this may take a while but for you
guys it'll be like two seconds so don't
worry about it
oh that was where the blue bowl was wait
I thought I found that maybe I oh oh I
think the blue ball was supposed to help
me find the stash wait a minute okay
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute I might have been really close I
just didn't know yet hey hang on
everybody's hold up a second so down
this hallway
it said walls walls all round blue balls
one blue blue balls on one we'll make a
sound
ah so if I look at Mikey ah I do I got
the can the blue ball defeat is stalled
Cool Ranch Doritos so I need to find the
stash but I bet the stash is along one
of these walls my blue ball is glowing
was really important I guess gold bars
I'm gonna be rich what's the batter
marks now strong enough no I'm totally
drunk
I gotta do it again everybody yeah stop
making me remember my failures another
one of Tim's entries Marga and I ran
through the facility a terrifying
monster right on our heels and just as
we were about to exit through the steel
door Marc dropped me willingly not
because I wanted to Tim barely escaped
by the splinters on my sides I didn't
sleep for weeks I learned to look on the
bright side I plastered a smile on my
face 24/7 but I finally snapped when
Marc used me to kill innocent people
when did I do that Tim I had no idea
that story sucked released something Bob
when did you become such a dick Bob's
like the coolest guy ever
yeah oh cool badass armor alrighty then
why o more radical suitable I still
don't have the wings why are you looking
at a spilt drink maybe that's a problem
if I don't have the wings who off stash
what the hell is it how beyond
recognition bah
obtained wharfs - cool
still no have the wings but maybe this
armor can prevent me from dying from the
explosion I don't know
these shells ah rocks my world okay
movie tiny buxom cut it out this instant
shut up you pathetic waste of a man you
you are the worst human being you left
me in that hellhole now Tim I had no
choice shut your trap I have inside me a
case of explosives soon they will
explode destroying this castle and your
only way home what not to mention I
destroyed all parts of your computer I
didn't want to do this or sash activate
does it feel good
can you feel the heroine coursing
through your veins what God you compute
a break each joy no no no no what no
that can't be right that I would never I
would never hurt my little biscuit I
would never hurt him I I'm back okay
well you holy crap
oh you're the developer now what are you
doing here I'm the creator of this game
uh okay I made this game for you
markiplier I made it because I wanted to
give something back
I received free videos every day and I
felt that I could do more than leave a
comment on one of your videos I've also
made a couple of animations of you on my
channel radical a soda and I'm sure
you'll put a link to it in the
description oh yes definitely no I will
I will don't li ji told you I gave you
here
you keep slogging along buddy this game
was actually my first attempt at one to
up it wasn't too bad I hope you enjoyed
it
yeah seeing yummy tie and having to kill
my little biscuit was just alive
yeah those horrible but with that all
said and done I think it's time to
conclude this thank you all so much for
playing and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye ah the end thank
you for playing you found the true
ending if you'd like to see my youtube
channel the username is radical soda
again thank you for playing and thank
you markiplier for all that you do for
us sincerely from me to you Thank You
radical soda for taking the time to make
this it was a look it was pretty
interesting like take oh oh oh we're
back again yeah there's the only way
that I wanted to end this video so yeah
just sincerely thank you for making this
thank you for taking the time out of
your life to make me a game about me it
was a lot of fun had a lot of creative
dialogue and hey no one else probably
would have made a game where I had to
kill tiny box sim and watched Yami die
that was traumatizing I'm gonna be
scarred for life I'm gonna lose sleep oh
hey you did it man thank you again
everybody for watching and thank you man
for making it to have the other fan made
games that I made in the description
below in the annotations over there and
as always I will see you in the next
video keep dancing everybody bye bye
that means you sir
you